seid ihr zusammen sagt einfach mal
herzlich und sondern wie gut ich habe
heute wieder zwei gäste neben mir und
zwar dennis und loreen die in der serie
kraft schule denn die und jacqueline
spielen und ihr habt einige fragen an
die beiden auch wenn es nun gestellt die
welt ihn heute stellen und der
wendehammer durchgehend billigten ist er
bereit
er bereitet euch den hardware klage
meine zuschauer zu stellen ok alles klar
die erste frage weil wir ja in der serie
ein paar darstellt logischerweise seid
ihr zusammen
wir können ja auch am schluss
beantworten denn dann machen wir ein
paar tagen war nicht auf den schluss
alles wird alles gut cliffhanger durch
erholen sowie waren die liebesszenen
zwischen euch vor was zum teil warum
liegen die linzer auf den boden oder
zumindest aus der wohnung dann ein 2000
fertig gemacht ja die vertraut seid ihr
da so miteinander hatte ich schon so wer
will dass die sagt okay oder ist sowohl
schwingt sich vor dem anderen ja also
ich finde mittlerweile da kennt sich ja
jetzt schon fast ein jahr ist er
vertraut schon allerhand verrückte
ganzen tag miteinander das wie eine
familie und jeder kind ein halb nackt
also wieder zeit kennen halten also auch
daran weil meine familie aber man hat
euch mal was
schöne grüße alle zuschauer land das
seit dem anfang von einer rolle gehalten
am anfang habe ich meine rolle gar nicht
gemacht muss ich wirklich sagen kenner
der kantine helfer an der junge hat
nicht gefallen hat ihm alles runter
gefallen also toll ja wirklich richtige
torwart und jetzt finde ich sie cool ich
meine sie zieht sich von mir aus so was
gehört das jackpot bekommen würde ich
auch ganz gern mal dass jobs tauschen
ja ich habe mich dass ihre freundin habe
ich habe euch hat nicht gesagt dass wir
jobs tauschen wollen hab ich das nächste
frage was macht euch am set am meisten
spaß was ist so was so am meisten bot
macht bei der ganzen sache ausgesagt
es ist schwer zu sagen ich glaube das
ganze gesamtpaket du kommst morgens
dahin du gehst ins kostüm reihen die
anderen leute sind da ist ja alles wie
eine familie wirklich jeder ist für
jeden da die verbringt den ganzen tag
mit deinen freunden sozusagen bekommt
dafür geld und spiels einfach eine rolle
die richtig bock macht also das richtig
spaß beim drehen und essen liebe liebe
kreisschule produktion können wir bitte
die brötchen zurückbringen das geht so
nicht weiter wie oft machst du der woche
sport und was aus mir ist zu ende
also auf jeden fall also ein blog muss
sein am tage nicht jeden tag sport jeden
tag was machst du ja also ich mache ja
auch so drei vier mal die woche oder so
was ja gut aber es gibt ja noch mit
sport dazu ok
wer mit wem dann es ist ja ja ja ja gut
los los oder was machen sie sonst
beruflich für jessica nur zwei also
äpfeln sonst ansonsten im
social-media-bereich dem fenster bern
haben wir einen blog und das mache ich
schon gleich bei instagram und nebenbei
noch personal trainer schreibt
fitnesspläne ernährungspläne zum 1 2
trifft
das übrigens auch schwierig der oma zu
erklären wäre das problem heute also
welt über bankkaufmann weil der ganze
körper nicht mehr erklären wie kommen
wir dazu bei so einer sendung zu machen
also bei der sendung speziell jetzt
mitzumachen ich wurde angeschrieben ob
ich nicht auf dem casting und ganz offen
ich war dem casting gegangen und hat ein
casting gedreht vor ort der produktion
das war über den suez kanal sowie gerne
auch bei sca meisten job wollen was auch
schon größere fenster ja okay okay
und dann habe ich ein paar wochen später
einen anruf bekommen gleich anfangen
darf und dann habe ich mir die sendung
angeschaut
okay das wäre also interessant dass
schule auch quasi unter influenza set
sind die anderen das auch weil die auf
forschung interaktiv die anderen
du warst ja dann ist aber die anderen
wenn ich nicht mehr haben durch das
schule sagt erst mit erst angefangen
okay das war bei dir auch so da wie du
wirst auch was sagen geschrieben ja so
ähnlich war es bei köln ihr habt ja dann
eine mini serie zweimal kurz zu sehen
und danach wurde ich ja noch im finstern
geschrieben auch kraß nächste frage ich
will immer so formulieren spielt hält
bei euch ein thema geht sagte hague weil
sieht man ihr markt geht dahin macht
allerdings so sagt tillich so gibt es
leute die dann so das zu ernst nehmen
und sich dann denken gebohrt das ist
nicht ihr redet nicht über
teilchenphysik das gefühl weil leute die
alles was gespielt wird erstmals zu
ernst nehmen das ganze denkt laska pure
realität ist ja okay das war's dann gibt
es unter anderem ja was gibst du
verhältst du spielst eine rolle nicht
gut gehört man auch manchmal so ich mag
ja noch nicht die stimme ist so ok ja
also es ist gar nicht so oft das
irgendwie leute sagen wie wir finden das
doof dass du bei einer serie zum
beispiel auch rtl2 jetzt mit spielst
oder so
das ist ja alles da leute meine freundin
kennt lohr ihren auch schon eine weile
hat einfach auf install die frage
gestellt ob ihre brüste gemacht sind an
der stelle springen wird direkt zur
nächsten frage danke doch eine frage die
nicht auch mega interessiert an jenny
mit deinem auge
du hast ja heterogene also und für
unterschiedliche augenfarbe
ich glaube leute denken auch erst mal
dass das irgendwie in kontakt - oder so
aber ist nicht mehr also viele denken
wirklich seinen kontakten sondern ich
hätte sehr viel oder ich könnte nicht
richtig sehen persönlich offline
das ist ein schlimmer jetzt suzuki test
müssen so so aus der entfernung so ein
so kleines bisschen milch wir sind
wieder mich ja also mit der weg es ist
kein getaktet ist
ich bin so geworden wo er manchmal
sorgen schwarz manchmal brauchen
manchmal grünen das ist jeden tag an als
echt dieses auge wechsel auf die farbe
beiden einnehmen also dass das event
manchmal dunkelgrün ein bisschen bleibe
ich auch glücklich und das ist manchmal
schwarz hält von lukas jaeger du bist ja
auch ein ganz anderen level das geht ja
kein anderes volk ist das neueste update
rtl2 wirbt damit dass ihr ohne filter
seid ja ja denkt ihr was das spiel
passiert spielt ist realistisch ja es
soll natürlich alles realistisch
dargestellt werden es soll die zuschauer
sollen ja auch denken es ist alles echt
was da passiert und deswegen ist glaube
ich auch dieses mies gefilmt wird das
ohne filter gefilmt wird und so das
heißt die wird ja davon habe ich
interessant ist dabei ich hab' ich hatte
tatsächlich fast ein bisschen ein
anderes bild mein bild war so dass das
auch schon so gespielt wird dass es eben
sich auch schon abgrenzt von kanal
irgendwie sondern zdf produktion oder so
dass man auch sofort erkennt das sind
sagt immer leiden schauspieler also das
kann man in den ländern vom sagen aber
das will ja nicht sagen
ja natürlich muss man schon ein bisschen
sagen ja dass qualität einfach bei
diesem format allerdings den nachteil
nicht so hoch ist wie im richtigen
format zwischen jahre ungefähr muss man
einfach zu gehen
das ist okay alles klar habt ihr ein
mitspracherecht bei der hauptstadt also
könnt ihr sagen
liga hat ich will das so nicht oder kann
man charakterlich das und das machen er
also mitspracherecht klar ist dass
hingeschrieben etwas überhaupt nicht
passt und überhaupt ist nicht machen
möchte muss früh genug sagen sondern
versuchen die auf deine bedürfnisse ein
bisschen einzugehen aber das ist nicht
sagen ich möchte mit dem zusammenschluss
mit dem zusammen seit ich mit dem
spielen das geht es ja also ich habe
die szene wo ich eigentlich niemand
zusammenkommen sollte aber das ist gar
nicht wollte mit der person habe ich es
auch oft man ehrlich gesagt und dann
muss wo es ja nicht so gemacht da kommen
wir dann zu fragen leute die ich am
anfang einfach auf gereist feld gestellt
habe und jetzt beantwortet wird seit ihr
zusammen sagt reimann
dieser sollte aber dürfen dazu halte
noch nicht sagen ist leider so gespannt
was auf mich zukommt in zukunft ja okay
dann legen wir dass leute die beiden
sind in der beschreibung verlinkt vielen
dank fürs mitmachen heute es war sehr
aufschlussreich und der check die beiden
bei kraft schule ab besonders schnell
raus